the scarlet king it says something that
in a multiverse full of terrifying
world-ending monsters like the sealed
king the hanged king a lot of kinks come
to think of it the crimson con himself
overpowers them all but today we want to
pose and hopefully answer an interesting
question how actually powerful is the
scarlet king after all he's apparently
the greatest threat the foundation has
ever faced we'd be fools to not analyze
what we're dealing with as an adversary
here despite his exploits being well
documented there's a lot about the
scarlet king's personal life we still
don't know what is he doing to pass the
time in that multiversal void while
awaiting his minions to open a portal
into our world does he have friends
fulfilling hobbies do you think he
watched squid game like the rest of us
we just don't know because of these gaps
in our knowledge we're taking a pretty
wide definition of power here we're not
only going to analyze the presumed
abilities of the king himself but also
his reputational and institutional power
including the abilities of the allies
and henchmen in his thrall and of course
to keep things balanced we're also going
to take a look at his weaknesses both
potential and confirmed to get a bigger
picture of the net power of the scarlet
king so grab your prophetical davite
tablets and find a grungy occult
warehouse near you we're gonna find out
just how powerful the king of the
darkness below really is first things
first what exactly is the scarlet king
according to the lore given to us by the
dust and blood tablet he's technically
an elder god born into a whole race of
god-like beings in the vast abyss below
the tree of life already before he even
developed his later powers it's clear
that this puts the scarlet king into an
entirely different weight class to any
human beings even anomalously enhanced
ones like abel or dr bright it's very
likely that the scarlet king's very
understanding of the concepts of life
and death differ greatly from what we
mere mortals think about the subject but
the scarlet king isn't your granddad's
elder god he spent the first eons of his
life becoming the greatest warlord that
the multiverse has ever known killing
and consuming his own siblings in order
to amass greater domination over the
darkness below as he slaughtered his way
through the ancient divine hierarchy he
not only expanded his territory he honed
his skills as a combatant even against
elder gods his own size the scarlet king
is an almost unstoppable warrior either
slaughtering his godly foes or scarring
them so bad that they bent the knee to
him and devote the rest of their lives
to service in short even without any of
his allies or anomalous powers he's a
true master when it comes to one-on-one
combat the scarlet king is also the kind
of tyrant who leads from the front
wanting to get even more red on his
iconic crimson armor after all what's
the fun in starting wars with everyone
if you don't get to bask in the glorious
thrill of bloodshed in mass carnage
right the scarlet king is a big believer
in loving what you do point is we're
looking at a warrior king who can
slaughter gods and goddesses with his
bare hands and takes great pleasure in
doing so to him humans are unusually
intelligent ants mocking him with their
love of life peace order and science
well for the most part anyway physically
he's astonishingly powerful but that
still leaves him with certain handicaps
for example his ability to traverse
dimensions is not what he wants it to be
thanks to the tireless work of groups
like the scp foundation every single one
of his attempts to physically enter our
universe has failed however this doesn't
mean that he doesn't have the power to
at least influence our world even if he
hasn't quite gotten the opportunity to
personally slam dunk planet earth into
the sun yet the scarlet king like a lot
of eldritch beings beyond human
comprehension is able to drive human
beings insane with the mere scope of his
abilities having easily broken the mind
of dr montauk when he learned of the
scarlet king's true nature the scarlet
king is also capable of bringing out the
worst in people projecting his boundless
desire for cruelty and malice into those
vulnerable to him as a truly ancient
being he's had eons of experience and
could easily outsmart and destroy the
psyche of any non-anomalous human being
arrogant or foolish enough to try to
face him from his scp-001 file as well
as the classified documents on procedure
110 montauk we also know that the
scarlet king is able to perceive things
in our dimension in a limited fashion
while he isn't truly omniscient outside
his own reality like our traditional
perception of the abrahamic god he can
sense feelings and energies his
favorites being hate cruelty and
violence however this strength can also
be used against him thanks to the
foundation's knowledge of how the
scarlet king's perceptive abilities work
for example they were able to trick the
scarlet king into buying their lie about
procedure 110 montauk simply through a
massive and coordinated information
campaign that convinced a huge number of
people that procedure 110 montauk
actually was a horrifying act of
profound inhumanity and if it worked
once in this fashion it could be used to
shield other things from the scarlet
king's knowledge creating a huge
weakness for this would-be conqueror
however the scarlet king doesn't need to
wage his evil war alone he is after all
the scarlet king an evil monarch whose
reign brings darkness and barbarism and
as such he's indivisible from the forces
who help him carry out his depraved
goals this segues nicely into our next
question about the power level of the
scarlet king what exactly are his
supposed armies who are his boots on the
ground we'll start with the human and
human adjacent probably the most common
of the groups that the foundation are
forced to counter are scarlet king
cultists such as members of groups like
the children of the scarlet king they
may not be the largest group of interest
or the most trained or well-funded but
they have one thing over all the other
gois truly boundless depravity if you
take a look over the full file for
scp-231
not only will you feel like you need a
shower you'll also realize that there
isn't anything these hooded monsters
wouldn't do in service of their dark
master kidnapping and murder are the two
more mild crimes like with most
dangerous cults the scarlet king's
followers are heavily decentralized and
may have nothing that easily pegs them
as his devotees the fact that he has
human eyes and ears hidden everywhere is
an undeniable feather in the king's
bloody crown but these non-anomalous
cultists only amount to a fraction of
the king's earthly forces he's had human
armies and civilizations pledge
allegiance to his cause over the course
of history take for example
scp-3838 the nomads of the 4th
dimensional step these tribes of turkmen
warriors exist in the exact same place
at vastly different points in time
traveling via a mysterious ritual and a
magical yurt at least one of these
tribes worship the scarlet king and have
a vested interest in his rule over all
things but of course no section about
the armies of the scarlet king would be
complete without his biggest fans a
little extinct culture known as the
davites well extinct for now at least
because as cp 140 an incomplete
chronicle always leaves the possibility
of their return as an open question so
who exactly were these ancient
conquerors just in case you've repressed
the memory the davites were an entire
society of hyper-violent monsters that
loved to use imperialism slavery and
subjugation to get whatever they wanted
and killed all who defied them think of
them like the british empire with more
magic and less tea they based their
entire civilizational philosophy on the
teachings and lifestyle of the scarlet
king which is to say absolute primal
brutality rules and he who can stomp on
everyone else is the leader and of
course nobody stomps harder than the
scarlet king if ever scp-140 was exposed
to too much ink or blood the daevites
would wind up ruling the modern world
and in all likelihood they'd do it in
the name of the scarlet king but those
are only his human and human adjacent
servants for starters he's also got a
legion of conquered elder gods who've
pledged fealty to him and are now some
of the most loyal warriors for their
brutal tyrant of a boss however even a
legion of elder gods is nothing compared
to the scarlet king's generals six of
his seven daughters funny even the most
evil nightmare being ever conceived
indulges in a little nepotism here and
there though in his defense it isn't
easy being a single father admittedly
that's only because he crushed their
mother the kind goddess sana to death in
cold blood each one of his daughters
gives him access to new armies and
powers the golden child atvik brings
tactical brilliance and advanced
knowledge of all things warfare with
children who are equally well versed in
the combat arts then there's agor who
makes up for what she lacks in quality
with sheer insane quantity her children
have produced obscenely large armies
that can overwhelm their foes like the
living tides of hatred and murder all of
which are loyal to the scarlet king
himself next adesap a desolate daughter
as mean and hateful as her dear old dad
her armies charge forth declaring
victory in the name of the king they
also have the ability to spread
devastating pestilence with their mere
presence making other armies deathly ill
and probably making
scp-049 feel extremely anxious he's also
got aziev probably his biggest scariest
daughter that appears in the form of a
giant unstoppable beast her armies are
also bestial nightmares and she herself
seems impossible to harm with any mortal
weapon there's atnot the scarlet king's
frailest daughter but a natural when it
comes to all things magic she and her
reality warping children are actually so
powerful that the scarlet king himself
felt a little threatened by them and he
had them all physically disabled now the
scarlet king has unfettered access to
powerful thaumaturgy at his disposal and
then there's atlif his most mysterious
daughter who prides herself on privacy
and is accordingly a master in the art
of stealth with her and her children
having the ability to change their faces
and walk among people unnoticed with
such absurdly huge armies a large number
of emissaries in our world and six
daughters who grant him obscene and
varied powers it's clear that the
scarlet king truly is the most powerful
enemy that the scp foundation has ever
faced however his most major weakness is
his seventh daughter and her offspring
ahabat the child of hope and the only
daughter strong in spirit enough to
fight back against her monstrous father
her children are great heroes and one of
them is believed to be
scp-999 the tickle monster the scarlet
king may have sown the seeds of his own
destruction as is prophesies that if
scp-999 is nurtured and continues to
grow he may one day become strong enough
to defeat the scarlet king's evil with
his sheer force of good with all these
scarlet king's strengths powers allies
and weaknesses i think we can
confidently answer the question how
actually powerful is the scarlet king to
put it simply he's extremely powerful
perhaps more powerful than anything else
out there but he's still not invincible
the next question is whether the
foundation can identify the cracks in
the scarlet king's blood-stained armor
before he enters our world and
annihilates everything we know and love
now go check out children of scp-001 the
scarlet king is scp-999 really his son
and
scp-001 scarlet king dustin blood for
more insider information on the first
word in pure undiluted evil